congi vas-y combien de tours déjà mathis
13 ans ne veut pas plonger
muriel sa mère et maître nageuse elle
lui demande de récupérer un corps en
plastique matisse ou narcisse dans le
mythe a une soeur jumelle dont il tombe
éperdument amoureux et cette soeur
jumelle moeurs et à chaque fois qu'il se
regarde dans l'eau son reflet il voit
cette voie cette soeur cette soeur perdu
et donc là le l'instant t de de cette
pièce là bas il doit aller chercher ce
morceau de plastique censé représenter
sa soeur dans le fond de l'eau deux
comédiens sur scène dans un lieu
atypique la moiteur la chaleur d'une
piscine comme une invitation à grandir à
quitter son cocon c'est vrai la piscine
ça lui est assez fascinant parce que de
haut niveau de l'acoustique ben on
n'entend pas pareil que quand on se
parle dans un des mêmes dans un décor
naturel parce qu'on a déjà travaillé
dans des décors naturels mais là c'est
vrai que c'est pas pareil on entend on
entend quelque chose d'un peu watts et
en même temps ça résonne
il y avait ça qui était intéressant il
ya aussi l'odeur tout le champ
sensorielle qui est convoqué pour pour
quand on y va déjà en tant que nageur du
coup c'était l'idée de se dire bah
qu'est ce que ça pourrait être être
spectateur de deux d'une histoire d'une
fable le deuil impossible remplace le
péché d'orgueil
le narcissisme le saut de l'ange est une
fable sur le courage comment se
régénérer se reconstruire j'ai peur
vous sautez 3d ton père car nous aurions
pu être un j'ai peur de me pencher de la
voir